(cool music)
- Oh my God.
- Thank you so much
for having...
I am freaking out right now.
- Oh my, am freaking out.
- I can't believe that we're together.
- I don't even know, if you know,
I wanna say it was at Nashville.
Did you open for Florence,
in the machine?
- Yes, I think so.
- Sure it was.
- It was so amazing.
I was literally at the show
with a bunch of friends
and I literally didn't know.
We showed up and I was like,
"Wait, who the hell is this?''
And y'all were so amazing.
- Oh my Gosh, thank you so much.
- Yeah.
- I'm so excited to be here.
I'll say it a million times.
- Okay.
I'm freaking out as well.
I thought you were so talented.
I was just like, 'What?''
And you also act now.
Congratulations.
- Yeah.
- I didn't know that.
- Random.
- That's amazing.
- Crazy.
- So wait, we are on
Universal Lot and I hear
that you always wanted to be a tour guide.
Is this true?
- Oh, that is the truth.
- I love that.
- I'm so happy that you brought that up
coz I've so many things to say about it.
(host laughs)
On one of my first birthdays,
I grew up in the valley which is...
We're here. We are in the valley.
And one of my first birthdays,
I was coming to Universal Studios,
and of course you do the Backlot Tour.
If you haven't got on the Backlot Tour
I can't recommend it enough.
- I love it.
- But you go through
all the different sets
of all these movies
and that was really like,
really like my love for movies
came to a wish and I started like,
becoming obsessed with movies.
And I know it from like back to front.
I've been over it like over 25 times.
- I love that.
- It was my dream to grow up
and be the tour guide
for the Universal Backlot Tour.
And am ready to go at a moment's notice.
- I love that.
- If anyone calls in sick
for the tram ride I will hop right in.
I don't need any training.
- What's been the craziest
moment like, on stage?
I've had a lot of crazy ones.
Where everything goes absolutely wrong.
- All the time.
My sister Este never... you know,
She trips constantly.
Always.
- Oh no!
- She trips con...
I don't know why but she does.
There's so many videos on
the internet of her falling
but I think for me (indistinct)
(host laughs)
But by the end of tour, I remember
it was like our last show,
for some reason me and my siblings
decided for this whole tour
that we were gonna wear
these leather pants which is...
I don't...
- If you ever gonna go on tour,
I do not
- You were sweating.
- I was sweating to my core.
(man laughs)
And I really do not recommend it.
And these pants, they had no give.
And I remember specifically
right before the show
because it was our last show,
we like packed everything up
and it was already on the bus
so I had no other clothes.
And I don't know what I did
but I might have like got low or something
and the back of my pants
just completely split open.
- This has happened to me.
- No.
- Since You've Been Gone music video.
- [Guest] Stop.
- My whole ass was hunging out.
- Oh my God, me too.
- Yeah.
Whole ass.
Not even a little.
Big old butt behind.
Just big whole behind.
Yeah.
- It's the craziest feeling.
- There's a draft.
- Yeah, there's a draft.
(audience laughs)
Exactly, there's a draft.
- Oh my God, I can't believe
that's happened to you.
- Oh yeah.
- You were on stage?
- I was on stage and because I was like,
''Oh okay, I'll just go.
I'll just run off stage
and the come back on with new pants.''
But then I realized that
I had packed everything
and it was like far away.
- What did you do?
- I just kept going.
- What?
- And I didn't turn around.
- We have different size asses.
That's not a possibility for me.
- Oh no!
(audience laughs)
I just was like,
''If I get through this,
it will be fine.
Am just gonna get through it.
But I fully...
I think it was just like,
I've never been more
stiff in my whole life.
I was just like holding my guitar.
- You're Beyonce.
You just keep going.
- Oh, I kept going.
- I kept going.
- Oh my God.
- But it was teribble.
I will never wear leather pants on stage.
- But here is the thing.
You might have never turned around
but the rest of the band and crew...
- Oh yeah, they got a show.
(host laughs)
They got a show.
They got the best view in the house.
- I love that you kept going.
But I have to ask this.
Is it true that you guys never let anyone
come into the studio?
But you did let Paul, right?
- Yeah, we let Paul.
- Why Paul?
- We love Paul's music taste.
I mean, he has the most
impeccable music taste
that I've ever seen in a human.
And he came, and saw us set up
and it inspired the first
project that we did together.
And we showed him like a couple of songs
but he heard Summer Girl,
and immediately was like,
''Oh! This is the one. We need
to do something with this.''
So we shot the music video.
We flew out to London to tell a label.
And that was when...
The night that I landed
in London to tell a label
that Summmer Girl was about to come out,
was when Paul sent me the
script for Licorice Pizza.
So it was like kind of all full circle.
- So organic.
I love that he saw that in you.
- He did.
- That kind of feels so like...
I mean he kinda built your confidence.
- Totally.
- Yeah.
- I mean I still feel
like am in seventh grade.
I think I have the confidence
of a seventh grader.
(host laughs)
- It did give me like
a boost to confidence.
- Next time you come too,
I wanna hear you play.
Y'all were so good.
- I would love to.
(audience claps)
- All right.
Well good luck.
The film is so awesome.
Like I said it's gonna be
an instant cult classic.
Everybody is loving' it.